it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all at exclusive discounts to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen or visit cdsdeals.com Candy
Carter Chief content officer of the
e-commerce company knocking joins us
right now candy speaking of knocking
candy
products that you guys go to CBS deals
right this minute go go go go okay so
love me today okay a lot of people will
be traveling this summer everybody when
you're uncomfortable it sucks oh my god
when your head it's bobbin you know the
whole thing so this guy created the Cabo
neck pillow it's got an extra layer
right here so your head literally
doesn't move I was kind of sleeping a
moment ago okay here put this on here I
love it and everybody's traveling so my
kids are out of school next week right
here can you even nothing's moving there
so this normally forty dollars 25 off
today
29.99 try this one on you're gonna love
it you're going to South Africa and
France yeah you're gonna eat this up is
this not amazing how great is that okay
love that great deal today that's the
Cabo neck pillow game changer for the
airplane okay
umbrella shade how many times have you
gotten in your car and burned your legs
yes yeah all day that's wrong all this
is guys
the subway
so look at this picture my car the other
day was 97 degrees I actually took a
picture of it look at that and I keep
this brella shade in the side but it's
also small enough for the glove
compartment see we opened it up so all
you got to do yeah super simple look
we're gonna do this here you just open
it up right everybody's backing up there
we go put it wider
yeah you put it right I know right it
keeps your car cool it keeps your car
cool you're not going to burn your legs
worse than that like ball of fire when
you open the door 100 so my in-laws live
in Louisiana my parents are in Arizona
all my people in Florida Texas holler at
me super super hot so two pack 24.99 you
guys they're like 12 bucks each and
Father's Day is coming up 100 no brainer
on the brella shade I use it all the
time take my kids to the pool whatever
cars you know the heat start eating guys
dig in all right so this is the Yukon
Glory can we all say Glory together
Glory okay this is what's so amazing
these are Grill tray but here's why
they're revolutionary they're small so
you can put individual things in each
because things don't cook at the same
speed right then you can also do steaks
and stuff on here but here check this
out it's got a little handle wow are you
serious right now so when these are on
the grill you pop them in this tray and
you can serve it's not even hot just
take this right pick it up yes and you
just put them in here look at my salmon
I was using this weekend I grilled a
bunch of stuff and you can also do look
at that that's my grill come on now how
pretty am I right there and you should
see my salmon delicious so check this
out normally 49 to 69.99 34 to 52.49
look at my salmon here's a tip you guys
it's so good right put these on the
grill and heat them up first super hot
then put your food in okay right then
you get a perfect sear clean doesn't get
the grill dirty how much um I just told
uh 34.99 to 52.49 okay amazing right
deal food was good right well it was
very good in here all right
right if you have any kind of weird
window shape you have an RV you have a
air conditioner and you have a little
space and bugs are getting in this is
the magic mesh magnetic screen you can
literally make a screen it's magnetic
look comes right off it's on any window
you guys because you just make it you
just put this on your window you put the
mesh on you cut it to the size and you
clip these on the outside you lift it up
open and close the window
right if you're a renter if you have
like those encasement windows in the
basement like anything where the bugs
how much you get in okay this is only I
think it's under 20 bucks hold on I got
you for 17.99
do you know how much it costs to buy a
screen you're right about that's a lot
of money you're the best
we partnered with all these companies
Burgers bills to buy anything that you
saw scan the QR code on your screen go
ahead and do it or head over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping now